depuis plus de 10 ans la directive est
claire au pays une femme devrait boire
un maximum de divers d'alcool par
semaine un homme 15 des recommandations
qui pourraient être revues à la baisse
selon un rapport commandé par Santé
Canada le risque zéro n'existe pas
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé au
début janvier a publié une recherche
dans laquelle elle indique clairement
qu'il y a aucune consommation d'alcool
qui soit sécuritaire pour la santé selon
le Centre canadien sur la dépendance et
l'usage de substances il faudrait
consommer un maximum d'un à deux verres
par semaine pour un risque faible sur la
santé 3 à 6 verres représenterait un
risque modéré de développer plusieurs
cancers comme celui du saint ou du côlon
cette verre ou plus par semaine
augmenterait en plus le risque de
souffrir d'une maladie du cœur ou d'un
AVC être raisonnable en étant au dessus
de cette limite oui je pense que ça va
m'inciter à faire de plus en plus
attention des experts questionnent les
conclusions du rapport c'est une lecture
des données scientifiques récentes que
je trouve biaisé aux États-Unis comme le
nae un organisme qui s'appelle le
National
recommandent toujours un verre par jour
pour une femme deux heures par jour pour
un homme maximum Santé Canada dit
examiner ce rapport éducalcool
pourraient éventuellement changer ses
directives la société
aussi évolue alors je pense que une
actualisation c'est de mise selon ce
qu'on peut lire dans le rapport l'alcool
a été la cause d'environ 18000 décès au
Canada en 2017 cette même année les
coûts associés à la consommation
d'alcool au pays s'élevait à plus de 16
milliards et demi de dollars soit bien
plus que les coups directs associés au
tabac aux opioïdes ou au cannabis ici
alors Radio-Canada Montréal